in the lobby of Ramsey solutions dan and
Jill or withers hey guys how are ya
welcome welcome where do y'all live
we're in Berwick Iowa Dave close to Des
Moines okay cool we love Des Moines
awesome very fun so I hear all the way
to Nashville to do a debt-free screen
yes I love it how much have you paid off
a hundred and seventy one thousand
dollars all right and how long did that
take
it took about seven and a half years
okay very cool making what kind of money
started at sixty ended up about 75 to 80
excellent very cool what do y'all do for
a living
I work for the director of operations
for Lutheran Church of hope in Ankeny
Iowa yeah and I'm a doctor's assistant
at a wolf eye clinic and we actually
both switched jobs during this too so
Wow this allowed us to do that okay cool
so is that home and everything yes
actually of your house yep so the first
of our debt we paid off seventy one
thousand dollars in 21 months mm-hmm the
same month that we paid that off we and
entered into a 15 year mortgage at
$100,000 we paid that off at five and a
half years Wow
very yeah cool I love that so what's
this house worth about two hundred and
ten thousand dollars and how old are you
- 43 but you've worked at it man like a
really really long haul but yeah so
worth it so what tell me the story what
happened at the beginning of this seven
and a half years ago when you started on
that consumer debt in the fall of 2008 I
signed us up for a class at Hope in West
Des Moines and he did not want to go I
went kicking and screaming Dave I
thought it was ridiculous that I have to
pay ninety five dollars to go to life
financial teach you to save money yeah
it does seem oxymoron yeah
yeah and and basically that check class
changed our lives and we discovered on
our budget that we were short three
hundred and thirty five dollars a month
from paying our bills hmm and that was
crazy
so we prayed about it and I actually got
a part-time job that paid $85 a week
mm-hmm
do the math it was a god thing I think I
made it was perfect yep
and Jill saw that it was actually
working so she got a part-time job oh
wow and then we have was her part-time
jobs oh fairway grocery stores yep so I
worked in the meat department she worked
in the produce department cool did they
give you a discounts on food no no but
we yeah but very flexible so when we
were done with our jobs we could go in
or leave whenever we needed to so it was
really nice option and then we got a
reputation of picking up part-time jobs
we've mowed lawns Lake Rick leaves waxed
cars cleaned kitchens detailed smoking
trailers you want it done we'll do it
yeah Wow just call us what's a smoking
truck commercial okay okay Wow I mean
you guys just whatever it took yep
anything anything that moved and paid
money you jump on it yep and we told
ourselves that when we paid off her
house every financial meeting we always
had our once on our list well I've had a
grill on my list for eight years Dave
never made it to the top never made it
to the top of the list but in December
because we paid our house off in
November 12 yeah and so in December we
contacted our friends that have a
hardware store and said that we wanted
to buy a grill and we wanted to buy it
from their new store that they opened
this past Monday mm-hmm and they were
all excited about it so Friday before
they open the store they had the weber
grill put away put together and it was
kind of in their way because they were
opening the new store in Ankeny
and so they delivered it on Friday and
Monday I went to pay for the grill I
wanted to be the first customer in the
line mm-hmm and her friends paid for the
grill
oh that's been paid and yeah Darrin
calls me at work and he's crying and I'm
like and Jill and Jill and I are gonna
feed a hundred people with that grill
May first at our house at 12:30 we're
gonna invite our neighbor our small
group our church and then we're gonna do
a community outreach this whole summer
every month we're going to go to another
single group or church members home to
feed a hundred people yeah
so hopefully what's your what's your
special to you on the grill you know I I
did a great chicken just a few days ago
so you're retired chefs oh yeah making
my mouth water yeah okay cool so when
you the bottom line of this is is that
when you don't have any payment you can
do whatever you want yep we're gonna
retire soon a lot of things on my list
he got his grill now shut up and get
back to work yeah but you don't have a
house famous yeah know how weird does
this feel and can I say one little story
Seidner that emergency fund mm-hmm if we
had not had that emergency fund we might
not have our oldest dog Eli we're we
don't have kids we have three dogs
Dobermans mm-hmm she had to have an
emergency surgery mm-hmm
we were able to choose to use that money
for that emergency and he's still with
us today they're with us on the trip
they're at the hotel Wow he was in the
hospital for a week he had a ruptured
gallbladder ooh
kind of a big deal for I guess big deal
for anybody
yeah they loved the Marriott it was it
was a total blessing to actually have
that option and we wouldn't have
otherwise Wow
it does it gives you a lot of options
that's fun all right so when people hear
you're 42 years old you have a paid-for
how
they have to look at you and go how did
you do that what do you tell them the
secret to this is it's a discipline and
for us if we had an opportunity of makes
and extra bucks or sell something we
didn't need we did those choices in
communication yeah it was the best thing
for our marriage mm-hmm yeah changed you
had a common goal and you were both
locked arms heads I go yeah does
everybody took a long time but we made
it yeah yeah but I mean your house is
paid yeah it's not like you paid off all
your consumer debt in 21 yes I mean
that's that's thinking incredible and
then then you just light into the house
and keep going that was awesome amazing
well very well done I'm very proud of
y'all thank you congratulations you are
your great American hero man this is
very cool you proven making $75,000 a
year 60,000 plus 9 million extra jobs
busting it and they've got a paid-for
house $250,000 house here at 42 years
old this is how it's done
this is exactly how it's done let's see
you beat the averages a little bit our
average is seven years to pay off your
home from the time you get out of that
and so you know you're getting you beat
it slightly but you've just torn into it
and you got a great house and you got a
great income and you've got a great
marriage and man it's very cool
yeah life is good it is good dan and
Jill Des Moines Iowa one hundred and
seventy one thousand dollars paid off by
the way that's their house did I mention
that seven and a half years making 60 to
75 a year count it down let's hear a
debt free scream our chains are gone
we've been set free my God my Savior has
ransomed me
Wow
well done you two you're fun hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind